it's time for scene and unseen where we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
for that we turn to Fox News contributor
Raymond Arroyo he's the author of the
unexpected light of Thomas Alva Edison
bookstores tomorrow all right Ray there
was a skirmish at the White House today
just as Ted lasso the cast showed up for
a visit yeah look Laura it all started
when an African reporter claimed he's
been ignored by the press secretary
we're not doing this we're not doing
this
imagine against some people in the
Britain and I'm saying that this the US
is not China
it's been seven months
welcome guys welcome welcome to the
Press briefing room undeterred
undeterred yeah Kareem Jean-Pierre she
brought on Jason Sudeikis and the Ted
lasso crew to talk about what else
Mental Health
it is sincerely an honor to visit the
White House and I have the opportunity
to speak to the president and to the
first lady about the importance of
mental health no matter who you are no
matter where you live no matter who you
voted for we all probably I assume we
all know someone who has uh or have been
that someone ourselves actually that's
struggled that's felt isolated that's
felt anxious we encourage everyone and
there's a big theme of the show is like
to check in with your you know your
neighbor your co-worker your friends
your family uh and ask how they're doing
we should all do our best to help take
care of each other that's that's my own
personal belief then the moment Ted
lasso and Company left the stage Laura
kjp made sure they were gone and then
she did her best to put those words into
action she really cared for that African
reporter who asked for help
this is the White House Press briefing
room a historic room
a room that should have decorum a room
where folks should respect their
colleagues and respect the guests that
are here what has just occurred this
last 10 15 minutes is unacceptable
it's concrete it is unacceptable so
we're gonna so we're either going to
continue the briefing or we can just end
the briefing right here uh I guess Simon
a table his mental health doesn't matter
at all just excoriate him publicly and
shame him in front of the entire press
score that's a good strategy the decorum
of the White House is she kidding me I
mean does anyone remember how uh uh
press people were screamed at who work
for Donald Trump I mean and Donald Trump
himself screamed at by Acosta and others
I mean give me a break nice try hiding
behind a you know a bunch of actors in
The Briefing room why do we need I mean
actors to speak out on mental health and
mental health is an issue it's a real
issue we don't need actors telling us
it's a real issue everybody knows it's a
real issue I'm waiting for Kevin Costner
to talk to Biden about beef sales and
maybe uh you know a little uh what's his
name uh the the who's the The Karate Kid
he can come in and teach them about
self-defense and policing this is crazy
I mean I'm sorry earlier today Laura the
president celebrated Persian New Year at
the White House and revealed another
hidden bit of his past
folks
you know
the Persian culture
is amazing as a student of the Persian
culture not a practitioner but a student
it's incredible where the world is where
the world wouldn't have been where out
without the culture yeah Laura I'm sure
he was studying the writings of
zoroaster at night at you know in
Scranton not give me a break now he's a
student of Persian culture watching a
rerun of Sinbad is not a student of
Persian culture Mr President commenting
on various beautiful silken rugs is also
not a but but expert on the Persian
culture I mean but you know what's so
Insidious about this lore he claim he
gave lip service to the girls and women
being persecuted in that country but
then he allows XI to make a deal between
Saudi Arabia as you mentioned at the top
of the show between Saudi Arabia and
Iran strengthening the mullahs and
weakening the position of those women
and the Persians who are the Civil
Society in Iran he's not helping them at
all
um Ray Biden vetoed his first build
today via video now the bill would have
prevented his administration from making
Investments based on the woke ESG
considerations and by the way we didn't
edit this I just signed this veto
because the legislation passed by the
Congress would put at risk the
retirement Savings of individuals across
the country they couldn't take into
consideration Investments that wouldn't
be impacted by climate impacted by
overpaying Executives and that's why I
decided to be to it
Laura somebody should have vetoed that
recording I mean the 150 million
separate people are impacted by these
retirement Investments which used to be
based on the return on those Investments
now Biden has added all these social uh
qualifications this is rawness and it
was the entire Congress Democrat and
Republican who passed this bill not just
Republicans Raymond and that outfit
tonight you look like you're about to do
a slam poetry reading in Greenwich
Village I very well made look at this
what is this like a Jim Nabors look
you're like disappearing into the black
Vision I'm just teasing you Raymond and
by the way congrats on the Edison book
Tour all the details are on Raymond
arroyo.com and we will see you to talk
about it more it's a deal all right I'll
wear a tie hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else